[Music]
so what do you think of the recent first
image of a black hole visualized from
the event horizon telescope
it's an incredible triumph of science in
itself the fact that there are black
holes which collide is not a surprise
and they seem to work exactly the way
they're supposed to work will we learn a
great deal from it I don't know I can
III we might but the kind of things we
learn won't really be about black holes
why there are black holes in nature of
that particular mass scale and why
they're so common may tell us something
about the structure evolution of
structure in the universe but I don't
think it's going to tell us anything new
about black holes but it's a triumph in
the sense that you go back a hundred
years and it was a continuous
development general relativity the
discovery of black holes LIGO the
incredible technology that went into
LIGO
it is something that I never would have
believed was gonna happen you know 30 40
years ago and I think it's a magnificent
the structure magnificent thing this
evolution of general relativity LIGO
high-precision ability to measure things
on a scale of 10 to the minus 21 so so
you're just astonishing though we just
them all this just has we focused to
this right picture is it different you
know you've thought a lot about black
holes is it how did you visualize them
in your mind and is the picture
different than you know was that no it
simply confirmed you know it's a
magnificent triumph to have confirmed
confirmed like direct observation yeah
that Einstein's theory of gravity at the
level of black hole collisions actually
works is awesome and it's really awesome
you know I know some of the people who
were involved in that they're just
ordinary people yeah and the idea that
they could carry this out I just am
shocked yeah just these little Homo
sapiens
yeah just these little monkeys yeah got
together right and took a picture of
slightly advanced lemurs
[Laughter]
you